Edwige souffre d'un trouble de la
bipolarité depuis son adolescence
diagnostiquer tardivement à ses 28 ans
son quotidien n'a pas toujours été
facile car comme 9 millions de personnes
en France elle possèdent un handicap
invisible les troupes de la bipolarité
ça se manifestent des fois par des
phases maniaques donc c'est des phases
où on est on a beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup d'idées beaucoup d'énergie
peut-être même un peu trop et des phases
dépressives où là on a peu d'énergie
on a envie de rien faire des idées
noires des choses comme ça un petit
café stabilisé grâce à son traitement et
de vie je travaille aujourd'hui au
centre médico-psychologique de
Saint-Cyr-l'École et également bénévole
aux communs café trop souvent selon elle
les handicaps invisibles sont incompris
ou minimisés si vous êtes en fauteuil
roulant tout de suite on va
effectivement vous aider ou vous tenir
la porte ou des choses comme ça quand on
a un handicap invisible on a
effectivement cet handicap là également
mais les gens vont pas le prendre en
compte en compte en fait ils vont pas le
prendre en considération ils vont
considérer que une personne ou le
handicap ne se voit pas qu'elle n'a pas
ce problème là en fait et que elle
devrait être mise à la même échelle que
les gens ordinaires on va dire et comme
toute maladie psychiatrique la
bipolarité peut faire peur alors Edwige
la cacher pendant longtemps
et du coup quatre donc ça fait 9 pendant
très longtemps je l'ai caché enfin il y
avait vraiment que un cercle très
restreint enfin mes proches enfin ma
famille était au courant mais voilà on
en parlait pas j'avais peut-être deux
amis et peut-être mon copain de l'époque
qui était au courant mais c'était tout
quoi et là en fait le fait que par
exemple dans mon métier je suis
médiatrice de santé père enfin voilà il
y a des choses où je maintenant j'ai
envie de porter son handicap et de de
qui soit plus visible du coup en fait et
j'ai plus envie de le cacher
le médiateur de santé père participe à
l'accompagnement au soutien et à
l'orientation des personnes en situation
de handicap en s'appuyant sur son
parcours personnel le fait d'avoir
accueilli et de vie en mars dernier ça
n'a été qu'un plus elle a son histoire
elle a aussi son vécu avec la maladie
qui est très aidant quand on voilà on
accompagne au quotidien les patients
ayant des difficultés psychiques elle
nous permet de réajuster nos maladresses
ou nos précipitations et c'est en ça que
c'est riche
j'aimerais beaucoup à travers mon
témoignage pouvoir libérer la parole
dans le sens que je pense que c'est que
à travers la parole que les choses
peuvent avancer après le choix est
propre à chacun dans le sens que chacun
est libre de vouloir parler de sa
maladie ou non mais je trouve que c'est
facilitant en fait de libérer la parole
de partager
sa propre expérience avec d'autres
personnes ça permet justement de se dire
on n'est pas seul en fait diabète
trouble de la mémoire dépression
sclérose en plaques endométriose 80 à
85% des handicaps sont invisibles
pourtant c'est le moins reconnu et connu